du côté du parlement ce sont les députés
qui se penche cet après midi dans
l'hémicycle sur la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire après le
sénat en début de semaine les sénateurs
qui ont adopté un amendement visant à
aménager le régime de responsabilité des
élus locaux et des employeurs et des
fonctionnaires est cependant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
le dispositif a été revu depuis en
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale alors que prévoit l'amendement
sénatorial
éléments de réponse avec david khalifa
se dédouaner de toute responsabilité
pénale en cas de non respect des
directives du plan de déconfinement
voilà tout l'objet de cet amendement
adopté par le sénat
nul ne peut voir sa responsabilité
pénale engagée du fait d'avoir pendant
la durée de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
déclarée à l'article 4 de la loi numéro
2020 tirer 290 du 23 mars 2020 d'urgence
pour faire face à l'épidémie de kobe 19
soit exposer autrui à un risque de
contamination par le coronavirus soit
causer ou contribuer à causer une telle
contamination
un sujet qui fait forcément débat dans
les camps de l'opposition même si
l'amendement précise que la
responsabilité n'est pas désengagé
si les faits sont commis
intentionnellement par négligence ou
violation des mesures prises durant
l'état d'urgence
de son côté marine le pen parle d'auto
amnistie du gouvernement car oui cette
protection juridique ne concerne pas
seulement les maires le texte concerne
tous ceux employés leurs élus locaux
fonctionnaires qui seront amenés à
prendre des mesures destinées à
permettre un retour à la vie économique
et sociale
cette disposition peut donc être un
moyen pour tous les membres du
gouvernement d'échapper à une poursuite
tout en sachant que le nombre de
plaintes les visant ne cesse d'augmenter
que ce soit à l'encontre d'edouard
philippe d'agnès busin d'olivier ferrand
ou encore de christophe castaner malgré
la prise de position du premier ministre
pour calmer l'embrasement autour de
cette polémique
le sénat a voté contre l'amendement
remaniée par le gouvernement donc pour
le maintien de l'aministie